let's go to michael in kansas city
missouri michael what's going on
um one of your previous callers
um i've had student loan debt my wife i
was able to graduate debt free
and we're able to pay for our master's
degrees
cash um you know everything questions
um
hey michael hey michael talk directly
into your phone man okay there you go
brother
perfect okay um i'm kind of opposite of
the previous caller
i had student loan debt through my
undergrad my wife graduated debt-free
we paid for our master's degrees with
cash
but my question is i've got about nine
thousand dollars left
and through the stimulus money coming in
and having a child in 2020 with the
child tax credit on our new tax return
do i wait and see what the uh president
does or do i go ahead and pay it off
pay it off paid off today pay it off
today
yeah yep okay yeah if we
wait around to see what bill is going to
pass through what
house in congress will be waiting a long
time and so to be able to control which
what you can control it's kind of like
the theme i feel like of the show today
uh and it's this don't put your future
and your destiny in washington dc's
hands so
i would 1 000 be paying it off michael
for me it's
it's a two-part thing number one um i
got to see what rachel's talking about
ringside i worked with some
extraordinary
i'm talking about brilliant high
character wonderful
young men and women who were in law
school who intentionally
chose to go do public service work
instead of going to big fancy firms
where they were going to have
big fancy salaries they chose to go do
this
work because they wanted to serve their
communities and because
if they did that work which is hard
grueling work for a decade
the government said we're going to come
in and wipe those loans away and then
when they got to year eight
and nine that went away
and so they had sacrificed not only
their direction in law school which if
you know anything about law school it's
just such a trajectory right it's hard
to circle back and do something
different
x number of years down the road but man
they had sacrificed
five to seven years of major earning
potential
because they were they were given this
promise right and so there's that i
think
i think rachel's super wise here's the
other thing
there is something in i don't share this
with everybody so i'm just going to tell
you what's in my heart
when i took out student loans and i had
six figures man my wife and i had six
degrees between us we
um and then i went and got another one
that the school paid for but i i
six degrees between us we had six
figures in student loans it was hard
i didn't realize on some of these loans
i took out what i was saying
all that stuff i was not an educated
um consumer when it came to that but at
the end of the day i signed my name to a
piece of paper
that said if you will help me get
through college for this money
i will pay you back and i have a
it's an it became an ethical issue for
me that i was working good jobs i had
money now this isn't everybody this i
was in a
fortunate position but i had jobs where
i had this money here and if i waited on
somebody to come in
and pay for it which is my tax dollars
anyway all of our tax dollars
i struggled with that personally so
you're in a situation where you're
holding money in your hand right now i
think the
in my estimation if you've got that
money the right thing to do
is to go ahead and pay that off now not
everybody shares that ethical deal
that's just me but that's just me
talking to you
michael person to person here but the
broader conversation as rachel's talking
about is
yeah man you don't ever want to wait on
those things to make their ways through
washington yeah yeah and depending on
you know getting into the
we don't have to go down this rabbit
hole but the student loan program
has really screwed up a lot of people's
lives now did they make the intentional
decision to go get into those loans
absolutely
but the whole program is so frustrating
to me on that level that i'm like i wish
it just almost
it just didn't even exist right that we
like went the old school way of of what
it looks like to go to school
debt-free um so when i hear the word
relief there is a part of me that i'm
like yeah i do
i want relief for people yeah they i
like they had no idea what was they were
signed up for yeah
yeah like you kind of like they just got
screwed in it even though i know they
signed their name to it but man
so there is something that i'm like i
don't know how it would be done or what
would be done or
what that looks like because it probably
you know we're not gonna get into the
politics of it but
i would love a level of relief for
people right at some level
whatever that looks like but i'm not
going to wait on washington just to
deliver it so let's
let's get to work because 0.2 if you got
it if you got it
you have it yes yes you got it you got
it um another thing is i've heard some
of these
some of these variants of the relief
bill have different um
things attached to them you're going to
owe us as much community service you're
going to owe us this much stuff
which i love i love some skin in the
game on that right i think that's good
but at the same time michael it goes
back to an earlier caller we had or
somebody here in the lobby when you take
something from somebody
and they attach strings to that gift
you're beholden to them right
so man good for you i appreciate that
question it's a good question i know
that
i can't tell you how many times we get
that call people are all over the
country or wrestling with do i wait what
do i do do i just stop paying on that
because there's no interest now and some
of it may go away later
um i just want to say keep going if you
can and i hope we can get this thing
untangled it's just
a mess seven ways to sunday right